القضيه وهذا التطور على الحدود
الاسرائيليه مع مصر واعود واذكر ببعض
الاخبار العاجله هيئه البث الاسرائيليه
اشارت الى تبادل اطلاق نار على الحدود مع
مصر جراء وصول مشتبه فيهم بينهم مسلحون
للمنطقه الحدوديه سيد عزام ابو عدس بالبعد
السياسي هل ممكن لهذا التطور ان ان يحمل
رساله
ما بالتاكيد هذا التطور يمكن ان يحمل
رساله كبيره جدا على البعد السياسي اولا
بان اذا كانت هذه عمليه وعمليه لها بعد
امني وكما بدات الاخبار الان تتحدث بان
هذه العمليه استثنائيه او ما يحدث هو حدث
استثنائي وغير معهود هي نفس اللغه التي
يستخدمها الاعلام العبري للتمهيد لعمليات
او الحدث الامني وبالتالي اذا كان فعلا
قوه بهذا الحجم 20 شخص مسلحين اداروا
اشتباك على الحدود الفلسطينيه ال المصريه
هذا هذا يعني باننا امام قوى منظمه اولا
ثانيا اذا اردنا ان نتحدث لطبيعه العلاقه
بين سكان غزه بين رفح المصريه ورفح
الفلسطينيه وعلاقه التقارب والانساب
والاقرباء العشائر التي بعضها مشترك بين
سيناء وبين غزه وايضا العلاقه التي
تحكم الكثير جدا من المعرفه والتقارب بين
اهالي سيناء واهالي قطاع غزه وبالتالي
هناك كثير من الود والكثير من دوافع
الانتقام والمسانده وانا في تقديري هذا
سيضع النظام المصري في موقف حرد جدا لا
سما ان الوضع الداخلي في مصر هو وضع غير
مستقر الازمه الاقتصاديه في مصر تضرب بعنف
وبشده حاله من الغليان والسخط على النظام
المصري بسبب سوء الوضع الداخلي ومن ثم سوء
اداره النظام للملف الفلسطيني والفضيحه
الاخيره التي فجرتها اسرائيل في محكمه
العدل الدوليه وبالتالي ان تذهب الان
الحكومه المصريه الى مواجهه مع ربما عشائر
افراد جهه مسلحه في سيناء في هذا الوقت
المعقد والصعب سيضيف عليها اعباء امنيه
وسياسيه بالاضافه الى تعميق حاله عدم
الاستقرار في مصر ومساله اشعال الحدود
الان ان تتكرر هذه العمليه يعني كما قلنا
20 شخص هذه طبيعه منظمه وليست عمل فردي
كما حدث في حادثه المجند محمد صلاح الذي
قتل قبل تق قبل عده اشهر ثلاثه جنود
اسرائيليين واصاب عدد اخرين هذهه ليست
حادثه فرديه هذه حادثه منظمه فربما سيكون
لذلك تداعيات كبيره جدا بمعنى انه على
الجيش الاسرائيلي الان البد بتامين هذهه
الحدود ووضع خطط عمليات وعلى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تضع سي عز محددات وخطوط
حمراء وقواعد ا